had one of the most entertaining players
in the world to watch so we got the
mains coming out here okay was ain't
messing around right now he's rocking
the harangue straight away blakazama
coming in with the oscar and we're in
howard estate again ladies and gentlemen
one of the more popular stages today
yeah um this one i don't think k whis
will mind this at all man you know be
having the horan down 3-4 at the uh at
the wall break the wall with the sweep
so let's see man have we got uk vs spain
all right poking away here now good luck
i was just on the ball already 10
seconds into the match yeah
oh
good chicken yo he's ready
yup he woke up on the road and you see
the reason why he's using that stance
back three is because it's only minus
ten it's only minus ten so azteca
doesn't have a good ten frame punish oh
my god but very good was any punish
though
okay it's gonna be a lot of damage big
rage here on the table
last mix up now for oh yeah okay nice
little punish there it's down for one
he's just getting the just frame
skyrockets ready loading them up
shipping them out boys oh back dash into
nothing yep confidence there from
cameras to go for that sweep
over the top let's go we're in the
corner now
doesn't have a wall break here but might
have one here not a great punisher from
black summer could have got from two
three
that's seeable now that's here below
that down one plus two yeah
oh big back three just to answer back
all the way to the other wall blue stuff
spent
oh my god
we have a raw hair later that last the
down back one two string high crushing
mid
very very good comeback from black armor
yeah
okay nice dock there ready for it
pushing forward just a little bit now
poke's coming out okay
i was just about to say nothing big
coming out and then
big just for inspire rockets if it's
just framed ladies and gentlemen it is
also safe
grade two are very difficult to pull off
and again
rolling choke the classic
okay yeah don't stay down man that's a
harangue
no punish wow on the power crush
okay usually black ops punishment very
very on point
still best of three guys unless it says
uh
finals in the name not semifinals we're
going to be doing best of threes
reversal
okay sending it forward here a little
bit
anyways what drops a combo here
gets the big uh
the big troll there
solid stuff from cameras right now
manny's really locking down black ozama
down four two though
yeah as he says it um
stays
does not pick up after combo watch the
blue stuff
oh my god
oh my god all right final round first
game black cuz i'm looking a little bit
shaky but he's still staying in there
though sam
he's staying in there i mean chaos is
definitely winning the pokemon but black
ozama just seems to get huge launches
here okay whisk it's one of his own here
this is to the wall
big damage from -10 launcher as well
really good stuff there in the match up
and k with one more hit's going to do it
and there it is the jabs
beautiful stuff thank you for taking the
first match
what happened there between you know
round four and round five that was
insane i don't know how okay was just
turned up the heat there i'm trying to
break it down in my head there that was
so in k was his favor how did yeah it
all comes down to that one mix-up right
so down three four um after that after
that low you're super minus you have to
take a mix up you have to you have to
just hold it up it's between a sweep or
the or the mid launcher the mid launcher
is only minus 10. asaka doesn't have a
10 frame punish she has a jab and it and
her jab is that's all she gets so for
chaos the risk reward is hey i go for
the the minus 10 mid a launcher and get
60
and if you block it you jab me and
that's all you're going to get so kevin
is using that really well because he
knows that oscar can't do anything about
it it's not like she hasn't got like a
gig ass one two to make you stop doing
that right so yeah kay was playing this
match up really well you saw him
chickening the the reversal as well
which means that he is too put on point
in here and he's gonna he's making
blakazama
guess guess a little bit and get a
little bit scared i think yeah i i
that's definitely where chaos's strength
lies you know and that's just sort of
super super like sweaty or eyeing
pressure like if you're underneath it
it's like wearing a blanket that's gonna
kick you in the face um but here we go
black azama switching out to the
infinite stage to see if he can have a
little bit more room to kind of back
away here from uh the harangue pressure
yeah hua wrong
hua rang yes good i mean blakazama does
like to go to the um to the infinite
stages quite often he wants to get that
life lead and uh just chill a little bit
make it hard for you to getting asico is
a defensive type character as well so
she is known to be someone that can be
very hard to get in on but look at this
beautiful
the power crush move just to beat out
the dash
really really good
okay
stopping his pressure with the grabs
here looking for her down forward too
is he that's the only thing she's gonna
get look at that launcher
will only get a jab so kay was using
that beautifully
drops the ender on the combo here
oh
you're going to put the reversal into
the new kick zabaki and you would think
that the kicks are back here a good move
versus horan but kaios is choosing his
shots picking his shot beautifully yeah
i mean there was definitely one of the
more intelligent players but wait a
minute black azama
blocks a really really important goal
here charges with the unblockable but
chaos is wise to that trick yeah
oh
the sky rocket okay okay we see you
black
but there it is again look at this
damage
look at his damage right now
okay whis oh no okay here we go range
available nice back is that 10.
yeah
that's gotta happen the rage drive is
guaranteed after that reversal so good
stuff from black ozama
1-1 here remember guys we did see them
go to final round here in the last game
and k was just swung it back here taking
a game of his own
yes it's still winner's bracket here
though
blacazama looking to create some space
between them
patience to stay down but still gets
clipped watch the rage
watch the rage
looking for that something special here
needs something
so afraid of the legs right now oh
okay yeah nice because off black is on
my now
one runway for evening up him and he's
staying in there man you could tell like
even though kay was a playing the match
up beautifully black zama
he's doing a good job
well i love those sneaky little tricks
right there double cross up
he doesn't really lose a lot for the day
for the crossover because he also has a
back turn launcher um oh wow but gets it
with the can guns shuts me up right
there and then
flips them over looking for okies just
outside of rage
oh nice
punishes the reversal he went for the
short reversal
so he wasn't able to beat that jfsr now
kay was his one ran away from moving
into winners finals but walks into the
downfall too
and black as i'm at oh dirty resets here
okay
uh oh uh oh oh the vortex has begun here
we go
what even happened there
that was crazy okay nine speeds out
oh no they're floppy
okay oh god super close super close
30 seconds
big whiff
oh my god it's so scrambly the mid again
no punish what's the rage double two
what's the rage
it's not dead yet
oh my tail is with one pixel remaining
is gonna take the set
just that little
right in the mouth just that was all he
needed right there didn't have to run
the risk do anything crazy that was so
cool and collected from kos what a
player what a player yeah absolutely
amazing there you saw black kazama doll
man oh man he kept it close